earlier today senator rand paul he
introduced a motion to dismiss the
impeachment trial against former
president trump on constitutional
grounds
now last night we reported that sources
had told us that the motion
would garner 45 votes which it did
signaling democrats will be
12 votes short of conviction at least
here now is florida senator rick scott
chair of the national republican
senatorial committee
senator what do the dems
get out of this aside from wasting
america's time and money is it just red
meat
to their increasingly left-wing base
so lori you're i'm in the capitol i
think there's a little bit of confusion
we're supposed to be there helping
families
but it's like we're in the kennedy
center it's a political show
i mean this has this has nothing to do
with what we should be doing at the
capitol
it's vindictive it's backward looking
it's unserious it's conscious
constitutionally sketchy
i mean the supreme court justice didn't
even show up today
it does nothing to help an american
family it doesn't
have anything to do with job creation
improving our schools
our military our law enforcement so it's
just political theater for the democrats
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
keep focused on what's good for florida
families
american families it's jobs education
get this economy going get the vaccine
out
the democrats it's just political
theater well on an issue that actually
does matter a federal judge
who was actually appointed to the bench
by president trump
has already taken action against biden's
100-day moratorium on deportations
and fox is reporting that after texas
sued over the policy the judge blocked
biden via temporary restraining order
from moving forward for at least 14 days
senator scott
at the same time you're getting pummeled
for blocking biden's dhs
pick who himself is of cuban descent but
he's also a radical open borders
uh pick not surprising for biden but how
big is this immigration
fight going to become oh i think i think
this is significant
look i'm from an immigration state we
love
immigration legal immigration in our
state not illegal immigration
so what's joe biden doing in his nominee
no don't secure the border
don't deport anybody all right they
so they want amnesty so what we're what
are we going to do we're not
we're going to not prevent somebody from
coming across the border
then we're going to provide them amnesty
and then we're just going to keep doing
this back and forth it doesn't solve
anything
we need to have we need to have
comprehensive immigration reform
and we want to take care of the daca
kids i had a bill to fix the tps program
that the democrats blocked twice on the
senate floor so
this is this is not what this country
voted for they didn't vote for open
borders they didn't vote for caravans
what happened you know you say what
happened to coven
we're so concerned about covid kids
can't go to school they're committing
suicide in some states because they're
so depressed
but we're going to just willy-nilly let
anyone cross the border infected not
infected
it's just it's just it's insanity
insanity we got a role as soon as biden
got elected it was going to be solved
remember
yeah yeah well everyone says yeah
everyone sees what's going on senator we
gotta roll but come back soon we have to
talk about florida
maybe taking the tokyo olympics